Justin Trudeau has decided like all
dictators do if you want a police date
you cannot let people defend themselves
with Firearms so Canada has just banned
virtually all firearms in the country
that include handguns and hunting rifles
now Justin Trudeau doesn't know what
side of the gun the bullet comes out of
he has no idea really what a gun is you
know his bodyguards have a lot of them
but that's really it
but he's against guns so against him
that Trudeau's government has just
banned a gun called The Butt Master
now you may recall the name since so
many mass shootings have been committed
with the butt master
well actually no there really isn't a
butt master in fact we think there's
only one butt master in history was
invented as a gag by a gun designer in
Tampa Florida 23 years ago actually a
fairly famous gun designer called Mark
Subaru who joins us right now
for coming on congratulations on having
the butt master banned by an entire
country but tell just tell us the
buttmaster was not designed for mass
shootings right
uh no I had no idea about mass shootings
yeah they weren't as popular back then
but uh yeah it's it's causing quite a
stink in Canada right now isn't it
so the butt master as far as I
understand it I've watched the video I
kind of want one but I don't think
they're any for sale but the butt master
is a single shot 22 long rifle with like
a spring-loaded striker it's like the
most primitive zip gun like in history
is that correct
yeah it's it's very simple and it's you
know it's kind of nicer than the average
pen gun that's out there but yeah it's
it's just one shot and as you saw you've
got to unscrew it and screw it back back
together can't talk screw back together
and I've actually got one right here or
the only one right here
yeah that's so that's something the only
one yeah yeah the only one I've had in
my possession for 23 years and somehow
it made it on the ban list which is
absurd as as you know which is why we're
talking about it so if they're even
Banning the butt master the the world's
only butt master that really should be
in the Smithsonian and I hope it will
someday be like how did they even know
the butt master exists who's doing their
firearms research do you think yeah
that's the weird thing you know when I
first got somebody in Canada sent me an
email and and they're like oh Mark
server you're God this is amazing you
know this like Master Level trolling and
of course I wasn't trolling from 23
years ago but yeah first I thought man
this is hilarious it's awesome but that
what you look on official can Canadian
documentation and you see butt master
and it's like you know how could they be
so so inept to do that it's like what
what staffer you know it's it's almost
like a game of Clue you know it's like
you know the idiot staffer with the
laptop in the cubicle you know that's
who did it and that's but that's just
part of it the story has so many
dimensions to it you know because
obviously Trudeau's been saying oh we're
getting rid of weapons of mass death and
destruction it's like well here's
something with one shot where do you get
run into a room and pull it out of your
your prison wallet and bang away with
one shot while everybody beats you to
death
I mean I guess the good news is he's a
fascist but he's also a buffoon and
that's the self-limiting fact about him
I appreciate your code if you ever make
the butt master set us up a couple aside
from you oh yeah we're probably gonna do
a run so yeah we'll let you know okay
good call me thank you so much thanks
very much take care subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight